It's an honor to meet you, Mr. President.
Well, welcome to the White House.
Come on up here, guys.
This is an important month here in America.
A lot of our Asian-American friends have been subject to real discrimination.
Hate only hides.
When good people talk about it and say how bad it is, it goes down.
So, thank you.
We want to say thank you, sincerely, for your decision...
...such as signing the COVID-19 Hate Crimes Act into law.
So, we just want to be a little help...
...and we truly appreciate the White House and the government's trying to find solutions.
People care a lot about what you say,...
...and what you're doing is good for all people.
It's not just your great talent, it's the message you're communicating.
It matters.